I don't know the story of Molly bloom
this is a true story and that's a crazy
story yeah there's nothing we know about
Sorkin is he never fictionalized as any
just 100% accurate and never changes
anything
what's going on today guys I'm Greg Alba
but the real rejects and me of the real
rejects I'm John Humphrey we're gonna
watch the trailer today for Molly's game
jeralds game now mafia games they love
the game this movie serves Jessica
Chastain Idris Elba Michael Cera Kevin
Costner Chris O'Dowd there's a lot of
people in this film more importantly
it's written by the great writer Aaron
Sorkin and I believe this is his
directorial debut oh boy I'm excited is
Soren into the director's chair I can't
wait for him to be criticized and be
like he should stick to just write all
the people to come out of the work and
tell me why they hate and/or love Aaron
Sorkin I wonder which director he'll
most take inspiration from of the many
directors he's worked with Danny Boyle
I'm thinking maybe a Fincher I mean it's
a story about Olympic class skier who
ran the world's most exclusive
high-stakes poker game and became an FBI
target
that's a sounds more like a Fisher movie
that's a combination of a lot of ideas
don't man Moneyball I'm Molly bloom do
you know about me this is a true story
not to spoil the ending that's when the
government raided my game and took all
of my money assuming all of it was made
illegally which it wasn't you couldn't
buy your win em all you couldn't buy me
a seat at the table keep it that way
because you don't break below when
you're breaking the ball able to find
out for sure she's so beautiful you
spent eight years running the world's
most exclusive glamorous and decadent
mancave the office you're into the
publishers certain elements that I can
get you a million and a half I guess I'm
just curious as to why you pass on what
would appear to be the only way out you
have these real names creative
differences so long that I'm accused of
breaking the plans
[Music]
[Music]
whoa whoa boy Jessica Chastain's so hot
need your syllabus so I think there's a
lot of great actresses out there right
now
and I think out of all the lists that I
have great actresses mm-hmm I think
Jessica Chastain's the hottest okay well
comment below and let us describe you
the real rejects guys just a contrasting
or Bryce Dallas Howard Michelle Williams
young will you prefer for Michelle
Monaghan or Emma Stone or Jennifer
Lawrence in terms of directing what I
found interesting about the trailer is
how stylized the directing was and I
feel like some of the cinematography the
director and cinematographer different
they work together but a lot of
cinematography there were certain
lighting and angles that were like that
looks Fincher inspired oh yeah sure yeah
which would make sense as his collab
would Fincher a couple times down I was
under the impression that okay because
this is Aaron Sorkin and his dialogue is
very much like a play and super snappy
snappy yes exact effect that III thought
like okay a lot of this trailer would
probably be a lot of just you know
simple angles and a lot of talking and
then I was like oh there's a lot of like
crazy angles in cutting around and I
know it's a trailer and that trailers do
that but it looks like the scenes in
general have a lot of different angles
and shots going on yeah which I was
impressed by cuz I thought he would be
one of the guys to have the approach of
I just really want the actors to just do
their scene and I just want to capture
you know see I'm the opposite instinct
actually just I associate Aaron Sorkin
with a certain level of energy and
rhythm I was actually not surprised at
all to see that this is at least as a
trailer I don't know how the movie
itself will play out but as a trailer
it's bouncy it's past it's all timed out
to this music and it's pretty dense you
like there's a lot coming at you in not
a huge window of time this seems like
the way it's edited will be very snappy
snappy very and and that's what kind of
surprised me whenever I see like an
Aaron Sorkin adapted thing it's like you
know I think like West Wing
org or Steve Jobs yeah yeah
at a time it's just like a couple of
angles and you're just really letting
the actors do their job that really
impressed me in terms of the visual
aesthetic that he was going for here oh
yeah and some of those explosion
sequences managed yeah shots like wall
or some crazy yeah she really and it's a
fascinating story yeah I didn't know
anything about this until seeing this
trailer he seems to be covering a lot
and it seems like how the narration will
be told would primarily be between Idris
Elba and Jessica Chastain cutting back a
lot so a lot of flashbacks for him to do
poker I can't think of a movie where
Aaron Sorkin wrote like sequences of
poker scenes oh I'm very interested in
Aaron Sorkin doing poker scene sounds
great yeah yeah I want to see this dude
right gamblers yeah but it is kind of it
was the kind of writing he doesn't like
that seems like a perfect fit right
there it seems like a playground I mean
the cast all looks really good I like I
like this back and forth between Andrew
Sullivan Jessica Chastain I almost
wonder if this movie's gonna have that
thing where part of it is taking place
with them just talking and the other
half is like seeing what all the events
are and stuff like that I think a lot of
cutting back and forth yeah it looked
like to me yeah I'll have that kind of
cool stylistic the semi narration
approach but really she's just talking
to her cell but in there
yeah and that was sort of the main motif
I grabbed from this is them you know
sifting through these details together
it looks like they have great chemistry
well they're there have a movie coming
out this weekend called the mountain
between us
oh boy yeah I've heard so many things
things about it really just seem like
they're probably sleeping with each
other their chemistry's too good oh man
they would be the most beautiful couple
they would be oh my god weld about
Jessica Chastain she's such a like she's
so great at playing powerful strong
women
yeah well and this one looks like she's
brought another faster to that again cuz
the last couple of those roles I've seen
her in have at least in the trailers I
saw had sort of a cold edge this one
looks like she's you know a person more
used to living the high life and more
used to living life with a single
similar kind of rhythm she's still very
competitive though yeah yeah yeah she
seems a bit more lively and a bit more
electric in general and the reason why I
think she's she's so good at playing
these like tough cold characters because
there's always a level of vulnerability
underneath everything and you see that
in the trailer you see that and you can
always tell something's bugging yeah
well she might be tough competitive at
times a little ruthless little cutthroat
you could always see that there's a
vulnerability I love this and I really
respect Jessica Chastain's work on
performance areas like that that's the
extra layer you gotta have in order to
understand why she is the way she is is
go to that level of vulnerability oh
yeah definitely when michael cera to man
I mean he's always like underneath that
awkward bubbly surface I'm like he's
probably feeling some comfortable
sharing them with the other characters
in the scene I have a strong feeling
Michael Cera might be a standout and
they're not really showing him in the
trailer but something tells me there's
gonna there's because he looks like one
of those cool young poker players and I
feel like he's gonna have something in
there where you're like you know Michael
sir oh it was really cool that's very
good man Michael Cera resurgence Molly's
game all right guys what do you think of
the trailer for Molly's game did you
love it did you hate it are you excited
for Jessica Chastain what do you think
of Jessica Chastain is she hot is she
fugly what do you think I think she's
hot idris elba who do you prefer Idris
Elba or Jessica Chastain Michael Cera
did you like him in Superbad you wish he
was a little more famous do you think
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world is
underrated do you like his music on
VanCamp subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification about debt Jenny
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram the
big ABBA
on Instagram and Twitter and check out
our patreon become a patron rejected a
flick